[Music]
you guys are the five the world has
received you so well with this show how
have your life changed since its
premiered walking places in New York is
different well a lot of times like be
like who do something do something you
better walk faster I'm like and supposed
to be there like 12 minutes ago this
haircut say I've gotten better at like
getting strangers to walk with me really
really quickly take a selfie while
walking because I'm chronically late but
I've been crazy they're people that we
admired and loved so much have now
become fans of ours and I feel even
awkward saying fans unity but they love
this show like we were talking earlier
about Chrissy Teigen John Bongiovi
Meghan Trainor these are people who we
always love that are like we love and
watch you you were talking about fans I
want to know what's the what kind of fan
mail are you guys getting these days do
they still do that amazing it's dm's now
okay Diaz so I think it's we're so much
more accessible than the original fat 5
work is literally instantly you can
connect with us online yeah and I think
we constantly get I get pictures of
rooms well people should I use what Rob
should I do you know tan gets fashion
questions all day long so a lot of our
fan mail is absolute is brought about
the fan art is just out of this I can
only imagine yeah we get people drawing
pictures of us which sometimes you get a
little emotional because you're like wow
you took a time out of your day to draw
a photo of me beautiful dream celebrity
expert who would you guys want to bring
on as a guest because she can cook she's
a mom I mean this isn't a celebrity but
you know I'm really even curious out
lately I don't like a chemist with like
products like I want like a like is
there like a celebrity I need like I
can't like why does that hyaluronic acid
make my stuff so soft Oh like I want to
know we're putting an ad out out there
we need a canvas
you